all right president biden rushing to
judgment yet again this time he's
demonizing border patrol agents clearly
not knowing all the facts the border
agents are furious here with reaction
she's once again reporting from the
border in del rio texas investigative
reporter sarah carter is with us sarah
as universal every border patrol contact
i have every every member of the union
i've talked to they are apoplectic and
they are angry and they feel they have
been unfairly demonized lied about and
they want an apology
absolutely sean there isn't a border
patrol agent or law enforcement official
here in del rio who isn't outraged by
president biden's statements that these
agents will pay or by vice president
kamala harris's statements
comparing what happened here in del rio
to slavery
i'm here at the international bridge
this uh international bridge border area
is right here with mexico has been shut
down for more than a week the community
has been feeling it they've not only
been feeling it economically but right
now the community is apoplectic as you
said about how the agents have been
treated we watched as community members
just regular folks came over here to the
bridge to bring water to the agents to
talk to law enforcement officials they
were bringing food to them i want you to
hear from a former he's just recently
retired a mounted police border patrol
trainer what he had to say his name is
rowdy ballard and he had a lot to say to
president biden
biden had said these border patrol
agents will pay the price how do you
feel about that when you think about
what they're saying this is the
president
it's honestly heartbreaking to know that
uh
you know we work for a
outfit like this that uh
they ask us to do our job and we do it
to the best of our abilities and um and
then we get this kind of a backlash do
you think it's dangerous that the
administration is making these kind of
comments to law enforcement officers of
course um
yeah they were they weren't asked to do
anything
other than their job and uh there was no
i've looked at the videos and the
pictures and there was no
they weren't whipping the haitians at
all i mean if anything they were just
using the reins to uh either create
distance from the haitians that some of
them were grabbing at the horse rains
and the bits either they were either
using
the rains to keep them away or they were
using the rains to
to drive the horses into the haitians to
move them off because they were
resisting
resisting the
commands of the agents
sean it's extremely frustrating for many
of the agents here this is a really
dangerous situation this border region
is filled with mountainous terrain rocky
conditions uh the area in which they
apprehended the migrants was actually an
area where they normally patrol with
boats that area was uh they were unable
to get their boats there that's why they
were trying to move the migrants they
say what's worse is that what president
biden and the administration did was put
a big target on them basically giving
others the right to target law
enforcement in a time that's really
stressful and strenuous for them they've
got to say that they want the biden
administration to back down they want an
apology and they want it right away and
by the way so do the people of del rio
all right sara carter thank you we
appreciate you that reported hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else